thank you
welcome to session 71 in the worlds of
speculative fiction series what we have
for this particular session is a fairly
short work which contains six short
stories by Catherine L Moore and they
all turn around an important hero which
you see on the front cover GRL of Jory
so we're going to be looking at this
heroine and at the legendary land of
jewelry as well as some other places
that the stories will take us and
Catherine Moore is somebody who we
looked at previously
looking at shamblo and some of her other
stories we mentioned jiril of Drury in
that in a much earlier session but I
wanted to go back to these particular
stories so compared to some of the other
sessions that we've done you might say
this will be be a little bit lighter in
the sense of not reading quite so much
this entire work is just 200 pages long
so you know very different than some of
the other sessions where we've been
covering over a thousand Pages at a time
but there's an awful lot to say about
Moore herself
her viewpoints URL as a character the
worlds that she's going to
and the influence that this character
had I should mention right off the bat
if you're new to this series well this
started out back in 2016 as a in-person
talk and discussion Series where we
would focus on an author and some
connected works it could be short
stories or novels or anything in between
in which there was a coherent narrative
world that was being presented and we'd
look at the World building and also at
important philosophical themes that
either were directly woven in or
referenced or which could be
Illuminating for these characters and we
often did a little bit of history and
biography and talking about how the
works were received or interpreted or
reinterpreted sometimes another media
and the the discussions would Verge all
over the place with covid we had to
after a while go online and we're doing
it in this format that you see right now
where I will you know talk for about 90
minutes about various topics we'll go
into the World building we'll talk about
important philosophical themes we'll
look at some of the things more herself
had said or did and we'll talk about the
the importance of this particular
character now I do want to point a few
things out so these stories and I'm just
going to read them over for you it
begins with black Gods kiss first
published in weird tales in 1934
followed by black odd Shadow same venue
weird Tales same year 1934 then we get
GRL meets Magic first published in weird
tales in 1935 the dark land same venue
1936 and then we get a very interesting
cross over one quest of the star Stone
which is not just Catherine Moore but
also her husband Henry kitner who she
worked with very closely published in
weird tales in 1930s 37 and then finally
helzgard published in 1939 and that is
the last of these six stories all
gathered together in this particular
volume now you notice weird Tales is the
location for all of this and that's a
reflection of the fact
that Moore not only had a regular place
to publish Ed did her husband Kutner and
they work together on a lot of stories
so much that you know people have said
including themselves well we're not sure
who wrote what parts where more ends and
kitner begins or vice versa but she's
not just a fantasy or sci-fi writer she
really is within that weird Tales
spectrum and this was recognized from
the beginning with her story Sean below
Moore has an incredible capacity to take
genres and subvert them and make them
weird right so we're going to talk more
about that but I just wanted to
highlight that from the beginning as we
be we approach these very interesting
stories because we've only got 200 pages
to cover
we're being we're we're presented with a
really wonderful opportunity we can go
into considerable depth of analysis and
examination and reference with all of
these and I think this is going to be
quite a great session I hope that you
have this and you can follow along or if
not perhaps you'll go back to these
stories and read them yourselves
they're really deserving of attention
more is a simply wonderful writer this
is part of the golden age of early
American fantasy and sci-fi and she
definitely is a heavy hitter although
not you know super super productive but
definitely a heavy hitter of that era so
we'll Begin by talking about
the land of Drury and some of the other
lands that she is developing out for us
and then we'll get into you know some of
the reception of this the influence that
uh jirrell of Jory had as a character
and then we'll get into some of the plot
and philosophical themes and talk about
who is
this jirell person and what is she
actually mean what is her significance
so a lot of stuff lined up for us to
shortly delve into
in talking about the narrative Universe
of these sixth general of jury stories
one of the first things that we have to
say is that the land of jury that you
know she's owner of the Mistress of has
men a castle all sorts of cool stuff
like that is not very much sketched out
at all and as a matter of fact most of
the action doesn't take place in jury
but rather in a whole bunch of other
locations many of which are what we
might call alternate Dimensions or
worlds that are part of this narrative
universe but are not situated in
medieval Earth France where Jory is
supposed to be now that said we begin at
the first story black Gods kiss Jory has
been and Concord has been taken by
Guillaume right we we see Jory being
unhelmed and then kissed by him and
thrown into uh some some dungeons right
uh jiral opened her yellow eyes on
Darkness she lay quiet for a while
collecting her scattered thoughts for a
while for a time she lay rigid in the
dark forcing herself to realization this
the sound of feet shifting on Stone
nearby brought her out of that
particular misery she sat up cautiously
feeling about her to determine what part
of jewelry its liege lady was imprisoned
she knew that the sound she heard must
be a century and by the Dank smell of
the darkness that she was underground in
one of the little dungeon cells of
course so we we find that she escapes
from that she creeps up the dark stairs
of the north turret and then she um you
know decides that she's going to go
underground after she meets up with the
priest who she has shrive her and then
um we we find out that she is going to
go not just underground but into
a terrible place right
so she's talking with the priest and um
he says you know think for that shame
there is atonement and Absolution and
for the death that death the Gates of
Heaven open wide but this other jirrell
never through all eternity may you come
out body or Soul if you venture down she
Shrugged to wreak my vengeance upon
Guillaume I would go if I knew that I
would burn in hell forever and then he
says something really interesting
Jarrell I think you do not understand
this is a worse fate than the deepest
depths of Hellfire this is this is
beyond all the bounds of hell that we
know and I think Satan's hottest Flames
were the breath of paradise compared to
what may befall you there and she says I
know do you think I'd Venture down if I
could not be sure where else could I
find such weapons as I need save outside
God's Dominion now what does this mean
the entire like you know God above devil
below this is going beyond that this is
transgressing even the boundaries of
creation and so she goes into the
dungeon and we get this really
interesting description about you know
going through these passageways and
those passageways that haven't been
built for human feet to travel it had
not been built for feet at all a narrow
polished shaft that corkscrewed round
and round a snake might have slipped in
and gone shooting down round and round
in dizzy circles but no snake on Earth
was big enough to fill that shaft right
something other than humans have built
this and we we read it was a long way
down before she'd gone very far the
Curious dizziness she'd known came over
her again a dizziness not entirely
induced by the spiral she Whirled around
but a deeper Atomic unsteadiness as if
not only she but the substances around
her were shifting there was something
queer about the angles of those curves
she was no scholar in Geometry or ought
else but she fought intuitively that the
bend and slant of the way she went Were
Somehow outside any other angles or
bends she had ever known
they led into the unknown in the dark
but it seemed that her obscurely that
they led into deeper darkness and
mystery than the merely physical as if
though she could not put it clearly into
Thoughts The Peculiar and exact lines of
the tunnel had been carefully angled to
lead through poly dimensional space as
well as through the underground perhaps
Through Time two so what we find is this
takes her to a different world
a world that is connected to our own
somehow but
also not our own
we get there and we read the walls had
fallen away and her feet struck a sudden
Rubble instead of the smooth floor the
darkness that had bandaged her eyes was
changed too indescribably it was no
longer Darkness but void not an absence
of light but nothingness Abyss is opened
around her yet she could see nothing she
only knew that she stood at the
threshold of some immense space and
since nameless things about her and
battled vainly against that nothingness
which was all her straining eyes could
see
and at her throat something constricted
painfully what is it her crucifix she
lifted her hand and found the chain of
her crucifix taut and vibrant about her
neck at that she smiled a little grimly
for she began to understand the crucifix
she found her hand shaking despite
herself but she unfastened the chain and
dropped the cross to the ground again we
see this going beyond the realm of
creation as understood through medieval
Christianity because all about her as
suddenly as The Awakening from a dream
the nothingness had opened out into
undreamed of distances she stood high on
a Hilltop under a sky Spangled with
strange Stars an entire world right with
its own sky and stars below she caught
glimpses of Misty planes and valleys
with mountain peaks Rising far away and
had her feet a ravenous circle of small
slovering blind things leaped with
clashing teeth so we find her now after
she's taken the crucifix off she is now
in a different world this is where she's
going to procure the weapon of the black
Gods because that will talk about a
little bit later on because what we find
in this story and in the Second Story
black God Shadow is that she is spending
time in this world first she spends it
in night time in the darkness of that
world
and then
we find that she goes back again why
does she go back because
Guillaume is calling to her from that
world and she needs to help him right it
is Guillaume calling Guillaume who you
slew is there no end to your Vengeance
have mercy on my murderous my murderous
release my soul from the dark Gods
torment right she wakes up and she
realizes that from the dark place
underground she has this other voice
calling out and she is going to go back
underground and she goes through the
spiral uh not staircase right and she
approaches the end
now we get to learn something else about
this world
when she came out out at last in the
open Darkness she scrambled to her feet
and stood panting sword in hand
straining her eyes against the
impenetrable dark of this place that
must be without counterpart anywhere in
the world or outside it she went forward
warily right and then she reaches the
end of the passage there was no visible
sign to tell her it was ended but as
before suddenly she sensed the
oppression of those vast weights of
Earth on all sides had lifted she was
standing at the threshold of a mighty
void the darkness had a different
quality and had her throat something
constricted she takes off the crucifix
again
and then
she stood at a cave mouth high on the
side of a hill staring out over the most
blazing day she had seen heat and light
shimmered in the Dazzle strangely
colored light heat that danced and shook
day over a dreadful land Jarrell cried
out inarticulately and clasped a hand
over her outraged eyes groping backwards
step by step into the Sheltering dark of
the cave night in this land was terrible
enough but day no she dared not look
upon the strange hell save when the
darkness veiled it so then she waits
until it becomes dark again and you know
that's probably enough of narrative
World from that particular story in the
third story we find jirell is pursuing
uh this this wizard Giro right and she
conquers another nearby Kingdom you know
over grizzard's Fallen drawbridge
Thunder jury's Warrior lady sword
swinging voice shouting hoarsely and you
know she's taken this Castle right and
she's trying to capture this Wizard and
it turns out that he's gone
now how has he gone well he's gone off
through a portal and this is a device
we're going to see in some of the other
ones into a different domain a different
land where by the way this wizard
is not the main show
so uh what we find is that they discover
uh
passageway right and none of her men at
arms are willing to follow along with
her she's the most courageous of them
and she marks this window right
um
and she finds that you know she jumps
through it and now there's just a
mouldering castle right so she goes
wandering around in this land finds a
naked girl lying and she's she's dying
and a tall woman stands above her this
is the ruler of that land right so some
very interesting Adventures ensue and we
find that uh
one of the places that GRL is going to
go is what is described as a bower in
Fairyland right she's uh essentially
being
magic off somewhere she'd come into a
tropical garden of great muted blooms
and jungle silences in the diffused
light the flowers not as sleepily among
the leaves hypnotically lovely
hypnotically soporific with their soft
colors and drowsy never-ending motion
the fragrance was overpowering she went
on slowly treading Moss that gave back
no sound here Under The Canopy of leaves
was a little separate World of Color and
silence and perfume dreamily she made
her way among the flowers right and
eventually she gets to the edge of this
jungle sanity and realization returned
to her at least she shook her redhead
dizzily and looked around half expecting
to see a Great Serpent sliding across
the the grass but there was nothing of
course she had dreamed right
a little bit later on we find that she's
placed into a
Corridor or rather a a you know place of
all sorts of doors right this is uh how
the the magician the wizardess who has
declared war between them is going to
punish her right the Sorceress
um
so what do we see here a gust of wind
blew in her face and rattled the door
through an inner Grill of iron looked
locked across the opening she saw a
Dazzle of whiteness like sun on snow in
the instant before she slammed the door
she moved along the wall and opened
another this time she was looking
through another lock Grill into a dark a
dimness of gray smoke shot through with
flame when she opened the next one she
caught her breath and stared before her
a thick Crystal Door separated her from
bottomless space she pressed her face to
the cold glass and stared out and down
nothingness met her gaze it was several
minutes before she could bring herself
to try the next door when she did
swinging it open timorously a familiar
sweetness of flour perfume floated out
she found herself gazing through a grill
of iron bars deep into that drowsy
Jungle of blossoms and scent and silence
which had crossed at the Mountain's foot
she was beginning to understand this
significance of the hall it must be from
here that jairaism by her magical
knowledge journeyed into other lands and
times and worlds through the doors that
opened between her domain and these
strange Outland places perhaps she had
sorcerer friends there and paid them
visits and brought back greater
knowledge stepping from world to World
from Century to Century through her
Enchanted
doorways so isn't that an interesting
vignette right
we have a confrontation between jairism
and Jory that comes later on in the
story and then she
um is has something even worse
inflicted upon her
jirell's whole world turned inside out
about her it was the shearest physical
Agony everything vanishes that terrible
shift took place she found her own body
being jerked inexplicably about in
reversal like nothing that any living
creature could have experienced before
it was a backward facing in a direction
which could have no existence until that
instant
and then we read this the thing spread
out before was so stupendous she would
have screamed if she'd possessed an
animate body
all life was open to her gaze the sight
was too immeasurable for her to grasp it
fully too vast for a human consciousness
to look upon it all save and Flash and
shudder glimpses without relation or
significance motion and immobility
existed simultaneously in the thing
before her endless activity shuttling to
and fro yet the whole vast Panorama was
frozen in a Timeless calm through which
a mighty pattern ran whose very
immensity was enough to strike Terror in
her soul threaded through it the
backward trail of her own life stretched
as she gazed upon it such floods of
conflicting emotion washed over her that
she could not see anything clearly but
she was fiercely insisting to her inner
Consciousness that she would not could
not look back there not could not and
all the while her sight was running past
days and weeks along the path which led
inexorably towards the one scene she
could not bear to think of she's seeing
her own life In Reverse right so this is
something amazing too right that she is
experiencing as jerism is
um forcing her into this now she will
conquer that sorceress I mean Gerald
always wins doesn't she in these stories
but now in the fourth story the dark
land
the land of
um Romney
we find that we get a little glimpse of
Jarrell in her jewelry Castle
very near to death right and we you know
see that her serving women's serving
women are watching over her the father
uh is Jervis is coming to give her last
rights and um
what we find however
is that he has to ask them where is your
lady
her bed is empty
gervas's hands close hard on his silver
crucifix and Under The Fringe of gray
hair his face crumpled suddenly into
grief our dear lady has dabbled too
often in Forbidden things he murmured to
himself about the crucifix too often
behind him trembling hand signed the
cross and odd Whispers were already
passing the word back down the crowded
stairs the Devil Himself has snatched
jirrell of joy body and soul out of her
deathbed
but it isn't the devil instead it's pav
the king of romna who has snatched her
from her deathbed and taking her to this
dark land right he says you've traveled
too often in Forbidden lands to be
ignored by us
who live in them he is in a forbidden
land right and there is in you a hot and
Savage strength that's no other woman in
any land possesses he wants her to be
his Queen right and he says as you died
in Jory Castle I seized you out of your
bed and snatched you body and soul over
the space curve that Parts this land
from yours you have awakened in your own
dark Kingdom now she doesn't want to be
queen of this right and so she's going
to seek out as she does in Black God's
kiss and you know a way to defeat him
and she is going to find this out uh
later on by talking to the White Witch
but first he will tell her something
so she um you know is trying to get away
uh talking about the mountain that she
was on moving and he says You must learn
that secret of your land of Romney it is
not constructed on the lines of your old
world and only by slow degrees as you
grow stronger in the magic which I will
teach you can you learn the full measure
of Romney's strangeness it's enough for
you to know now that distances here are
measured in different terms from those
you know space and matter are
subordinated to the power of the mind so
that when you desire to reach a place
you need only concentrate on it to bring
it into Focus about you succeeding the
old landscape in which you stood later
you must see Roman in its true reality
walk through Rome as romna really is
when you are my queen
now this is again very interesting right
we see the pattern the Trope of new
forbidden worlds uh coming up now she is
going to again defeat him and get back
to her old world and then we get an even
stranger Story one the way that we've uh
you know
seen from a different perspective in a
different world the quest of the star
Stone which by the way is a
collaboration between Catherine Moore
and Henry Kutner and more is known at
this time not just for jirel of Jory
stories this is the fifth of them but
for Northwest Smith stories beginning
with Sean blow and going onward
this is one where two narrative worlds
are going to intersect
so there's a wizard again right as there
so often is and he brings Northwest
Smith into his own world and he tells uh
Smith that
what you have to do is get the lady of
Joy through this Gateway the same
Gateway that you came hither but it will
take you into another land where there
are powers favorable to me and therefore
to you why is he doing this because he
wants to get the star Stone from GRL of
jury and so he's enlisted Northwest
Smith and his friend His companion the
Martian franga to do that and so uh
Smith goes into the land of jury along
with franga meets up with jirrell right
uh and uh they you know they're they're
met by a bunch of knights uh they're
taken to
um the castle over the drawbridge under
the spiked porticolas into the high
vaulted smoke black and Banquet Hall
where GRL sat at a midday table this is
about as much description as we get of
Castle Jory as any other place and then
Smith actually
um
you know casts the spell and they get
through the doorway into this uh place
which is essentially you know another
dimension controlled by this wizard who
it you know is intending for uh Jory
jiral of Jory to give him the the stone
now
Smith and his Martian companion and
Gerald of Jory pretty quickly realized
that this wizard is bad news and they
tell them you're not going to get the
star Stone so he leaves and they begin
exploring the land and they find that
it's pretty awful I'll just read you a
little bit of this
the spongy ground was wicked to walk on
they stumbled against one another
swearing in a variety of tongues at the
blinding air they groped through the
hard going underfoot The Wretched
uncertainty that kept their eyes
scanning The Dazzle as they walked now
here's where it gets worse
it was Jiro who first caught sight of
the shrunken Brown thing indeed she
almost stumbled over at a mummified body
curled up on its side so it's bony knees
nearly touched the brown fleshless
forehead Smith turned at her little gas
saw the thing and paused to bend over it
wonderingly it was not pleasant to see
all right and then yarl says come along
certainly he can't help us or harm us
either
silently ascending Smith swung on his
heel but some instinct
the little tingling danger note that
Whispers in the back of a space man's
head made him turn the position of the
recumbent figure had changed its head
was lifted and it was staring at him
with a swollen glazed eyes now the thing
should have been dead Smith knew that
somehow with a dreadful certainty
the limbs of the twitched and
moved slowly and the skeletal tattered
body arose it dragged itself forward
among the whirling star moats and
instinctively Smith recoiled there was
something so unadder unutterably dreary
about it despite the Dreadful attitude
of hunger that thrust its BEAST's head
forward that he sickened a little as he
stared from gyrell came a little cry of
repugnance quickly muffled we'd better
get out of here said Smith harshly and
then they realize there's more of these
things and they use their heat guns
to burn them
one of the approaching Horrors toppled
over the left arm completely burned from
its body
then it regained its balance and crawled
forward with a crab like sidewise motion
and yarl says can't they die so what we
find here is in this world that the
wizard has left them in there are what
do we want to call them zombies mummies
the undead pursuing them slowly but
surely on the spongy Earth so that's you
know kind of an interesting uh vignette
as well they do get their way out of
this world and then we get ourselves to
the sixth and final jirell of jury story
now this one is in a place called Hells
guard
and GRL once again has gone ahead of her
men who are too scared uh he is per
she's pursuing this particular guy who
she's uh you know Finding comely but
also treacherous and uh Hells guard is
known for a hideous old story about
andred who had been a big violent man
passionate and willful and very cruel
men hated him but when the tale of his
dying spread abroad his enemies pitted
at Android of Hell's guard for the rumor
of his treasure had drawn at least
besiegers who he could not overcome the
gate had fallen and the robber Nobles
who captured the castle searched in vain
for the precious casket which Android
guarded torture could not loosen his
lips though they tried very terribly to
make him speak he was a powerful man
stubborn and brave he lived a long while
under torment but he would not betray
The Hiding Place his treasure they tore
him limb from limb at last and cast his
dismembered body into the quicksands and
came away empty-handed since then for
200 years hell's guard had laying empty
it was a dismal Place full of Mists and
fevers from the marsh and Andrew did not
lie easy in the quicksands whereas
murderers had cast him dismembered and
Scattered broadcast over the marshes he
would not lie quiet
people have gone there to seek the
treasure and they always die
that's where jirel is so we find her
encountering a bunch of people who claim
to be related to ons guard right and she
asks them
um hell's guard of the marshes has an
ugly reputation I wonder how you dare
dwell here or do you know the old Tale
and he Alaric says yes we know the tale
We're Not Afraid
and suddenly jirella was quite sure of a
strange thing something in his voice and
his words told her very surely that
they'd not come in spite of the terrible
old Legend but because of it
and so they're going to spend some time
in this awful abandoned terrifying
Castle
and what we're going to find is GRL is
going to actually encounter anscard or
Android twice
the second time that she encounters him
there's a vortex
spinning and narrowing as if the whole
force that was Android were
concentrating into one tornado whirl of
savage power perhaps it was that feeling
of narrowing and Vortex vortexing
rotation which made walls seem to close
about her it was all too dimly sensed a
thing to put into words yet it was
terribly real right and so what does she
find the walls were very near uh she
groped dizzily through the haze of
confusion she knew that this that this
then must be his own place once again a
new different dimension a terrifying
place outside of the boundaries of our
world a place of stone and damp and
darkness somehow outside for they'd
reached it too quickly for it to be a
real place and yet it was tangible stone
walls Cold against her hands and what
were these round and slipping things
under foot right she manages to get
herself out of that and there's more to
the story but I'm going to skip over
that for right now so what do we have
within this narrative Universe all sorts
of
weird places that you can access by
magic by going through tunnels by doing
certain spells and portals and even you
know being dragged out of your existence
by the Lord of that Dimension these are
all packed into these six short stories
found in you know a little over 200
Pages 201 pages
coming out of the Mind
of Cl more these are all places and
spaces that jirell will Traverse this
great heroine of these six stories
there's a considerable amount that's
said about CL Moore and her GRL of jury
character in various academic Works
where you know they're looking at
popular culture and having some very
revealing interesting provocative things
to say about it so I'd like to do a
little bit of a summary of some of that
engaging with it and thinking about this
as well because this does tie in with
philosophical themes namely what gender
is what kind of character jiril is uh
how CL Moore is working with her to take
a literary genre and do something quite
different with it and I want to begin
with a interesting quotation from CL
Moore in the best of Cl Moore she
actually says something I think quite
provocative here's what it is if you
have bread past shamblo to jirell you
will probably have noticed what a close
relationship the two women bear to one
another I realize now that unconsciously
No Doubt both were versions of the self
I'd like to have been so in a certain
sense she's admitting that jiril of jury
is in part a projection of not who she
thinks she is but of the self notice she
doesn't say of the woman but the self
who I'd have liked to have been and it's
interesting that she's contrasting these
two and also bringing them together Sean
blow which essentially puts her on the
map and then she follows up with these
sequence of GRL of Jory stories as well
as some others as well in that time all
in the same pulp environment now there's
a lot to bring up so we're going to jump
right into it one that I'd like to start
by by looking at and we're going to be
talking about her reception at first is
coming from a thesis by Anthony
chaffello gendered and genderified
bodies heroism as production and
performance in sword and sorcery fantasy
and we're going to come back to this one
later as well so here's what what's in
there science fiction historian Sam
Moskowitz calls more the most important
female writer of imaginative fiction
since Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
published in 1818. in an interview with
Moscow it's more confessed as soon as I
could talk I began telling long obscure
Tales to anyone I could Corner when I
learned to write I wrote them and I have
been at it ever since I was reared on a
diet of Greek mythology Oz books and
Edgar Rice Burroughs I wrote about
Cowboys and Kings hot Robin hoods and
lancelots and Tarzan's thinly disguised
under other names there's a lot of
apprenticing going on a lot of working
with these things she's not just you
know making stuff up out of whole cloth
as we say and uh chiefello goes on and
says while she does not Merit her own
chapter and else Sprague to Camp's
literary Swordsmen and Sorcerers we
might say a similar thing to about Damon
Knight's book about Science Fiction and
Fantasy as well where she's paired in
with Henry Kutner she is featured as the
first of the Conan's comp peers chapter
Moore's craft is isolated by numerous
sword and sorcery authors anthologists
and critics including the camp and more
as perhaps sword and sorceries
finest author Moore was neither the
first woman writer of speculative
fiction nor the most prolific but she
was arguably the most popular and the
most lasting there's an assumption of
male readership and authorship among
sword and sorcery pulps in its dedicated
section to reader submissions entitled
the Eerie letters from women were
frequently featured this implies that
the editors of weird tales in particular
did not view their Magazine's contents
including the blossoming genre of sword
and sorcery as a strictly male space so
those are some interesting things about
her influence right there
another thing comes up in Frankenstein's
daughters the problem of the feminine
image in science fiction by Patricia
Monk and she writes although
Frankenstein or the modern Prometheus
which is popularly considered to be one
of the most important prototypes of the
modern science fiction novel was written
by a by a woman Mary Shelley and became
immediately successful on its
publication in 1818. this promising
start was not followed up with either
success or enthusiasm by other women
writers there's a handful of extant
science fiction novels by women writers
in the 19th century but apparently no
women writer contemporary with the
earliest major male writers Jules Verne
or h.j Wells produced science fiction on
the same large scale as they did nor was
the early 20th century much more
promising for the emergence of women
writers for not until the 19 the early
1940s actually 30s did writers such as
CL Moore lay bracket and a handful of
others make themselves felt in the field
and then she goes on to say since it was
the men in the 19th century who assigned
to women their second class status male
writers reflected the same kind of
assumptions about the status of women
and even in science fiction despite the
genres claimed to be forward-looking or
revolutionary in its um in its thinking
and she goes out and she talks about the
second class status of women in the
thinking of such male writers tended to
have the same Authority as the laws of
gravity it was a known fact and one of
the basic rules of the genres that in
science fiction nothing May contradict a
known fact of science or the story
ceases to be science fiction and
dwindles into mere fantasy now notice
that mirror fantasy these two closely
Allied speculative fiction genres tied
together in weird Tales
more is going to excel in both science
fiction and in fantasy but by doing some
of the same things in Virginia Wolfe's
Andre Norton feminist Pied Piper in
science fiction which is mostly about
Andre Norton there's an interesting
mention of uh CL Moore as well Andre
Norton is never to my knowledge called
herself a feminist
um
as she herself relates an on writing
fantasy she wrote only of Heroes in
early work or females serving merely as
props but in the 1960s
inspired by CL Moore's GRL of jury
Norton broke the old pattern Robert
sloven would reject these strong
independent female characters of the
Witch World Moon singer and four novel
Forerunner novels as a breakthrough for
science fiction why because he
identifies them as once again fantasy in
1970 with a publication of ice Crown uh
Norton made a female the protagonist of
what is an indisputably a science
fiction novel since then most of her
science fiction has offered strong
female characters now what are we seeing
here so Andre Norton is one of many
female science fiction authors and
jirelle of jewelry plays an important
role and so to see how more in getting
her to experiment to try out female not
just crops but leads but notice once
again the dismissal of oh that's just
fantasy it's not science fiction as such
Andrew Wilson writes in lost as Atlantis
now classical influences in the work of
Cl Moore which I strongly advise
checking out just for that classical
influences thing
something about what happened in one of
the novels
with Henry Kutner Moore wrote quest of
the star Stone which we'll talk about
shortly in more detail in which jirelle
and Northwest Smith meet now
these are both Moore's characters not
kutner's characters but they're
collaborating together on a crossover
story after this collaboration Moore and
Kutner not only married but also formed
a creative partnership that produced
under several pseudonyms a prodigious
amount of Science Fiction and Fantasy
literature arguably when writing under
such aliases as Lawrence O'Donnell or
Louis Padgett Moore was echoing the
uncertainty of classical scholarship as
to whether the work of figures such as
Homer refers to the creation of one or
many authors according to the
Encyclopedia of Science Fiction so this
is being quoted from there most of more
in kutner's Works between 1940 and his
death in 1958 were to some extent
collaborations each writer reportedly
being able to pick up any story where
the other had left off and it is proved
futile well to attempt to determine who
may have been the solar senior author of
many tales published under their own are
there several shared names so now it
gets much more interesting doesn't it
these collaborative writers not
pertaining so much to jirel of Jory uh
we're going to see this this
mixing together is going to play an
important role in what's going on in
general of Joy stories
but they form this
romantic attachment this artistic
collaboration that goes on throughout
their marriage until uh kutner's death
in which after which Moore is actually
going to leave behind fantasy and
science fiction writing and write for
television
um in
mediating more uncertain Origins and
indeterminate identities in the work of
Cl Moore another dissertation by
Jennifer Lynn jodo first we read this
interesting piece in an open letter to
CL Moore a piece written for the program
of the 1981 worldcon in which more was a
guest of honor writer Robert bloke
another major fantasy and science
fiction author describes his first
meeting with Moore as well as her impact
on the science fiction and science
fantasy Fields as they existed in 1933
do you remember a long ago Day in May
1937 when you and your friend Marjorie
paid your first visit to California you
were still working as a bank secretary
back in Indianapolis your hometown but
already you'd become quite a famous lady
or perhaps a famous young man that's
what the readers of weird Tales thought
when they read your tricky byline CL
more on your very first story shamblo
published back in 33 and catapulted you
immediately into the front ranks of
science fantasy writers the first gal
who'd made it in the 117 years since the
publication of Frankenstein those series
of years
Northwest Smith and girelle of Jory were
top favorites and now you were writing
legitimate science fiction for
astounding stories by this time 1937 of
course the secret was out you were
definitely feminine and attractive no
wonder Henry Kutner fell for you later
on in the the work
um
jodelle is going to write about more
relating something in her interview with
chakal Jarrell of jury's popularity was
also probably due to the fact that she
broke Convention as indicated by her
name of Jory Jarrell is clearly property
the Mistress of a castle its territories
and her men well she and Smith Northwest
Smith are similar in that they both lead
somewhat hedonistic existences and
possess cores of violence
in contrast to Northwest reluctant
curiosity in naivete
jirell bounds into danger with sword
drawn and smoldering curses to announce
her intentions a tall muscular and
headstrong tough girl the fall mouth
girol is certainly not the extraneous
background figure of the science fiction
mode nor is she the helpless female of
the gothic additionally Giro fails to
meet the Criterion of a heroine of
atteberry's feminine Gothic in the sense
that while Gerald does possess limited
Ambitions such as maintaining jory's
treasury similar to Smith marriage is
not one of them so what we've got here
is a clearly boundary and genre
transgressing character being offered to
readers in the pulp by Catherine Moore
now we go on as well in this and yet as
anthologist Carl Edward Wagner another
major later fantasy right writer and
horror writer too notes in his
introduction to Echoes of Valor too
jirrell is not simply as some may have
said
Conan in a woman's body so here's what
he says
as with Conan the Prototype is not
easily surpassed
like her Creator GRL was a red-haired
Beauty and fiercely independent arguably
one of the genre's first liberated
heroines Jarrell was not simply Conan in
a black brass bra more portrayed URL
with a depth of characterization and a
sure grasp of feminine feeling that
place Jerrell Generations beyond the
rest of the pulp field
then uh here we go jodelle goes on to
say it's important to note that though
Moore's heroine seems to possess
feminine feeling as as Wagner puts it
Jarrell does not find love indeed more
has been criticized for as Sarah gamble
claims never presenting a quote single
example of an uncomplicated happy love
affair For Love and Death just as much
as sex and erotic Annihilation are
irrevocably linked throughout her
fiction although some might argue that
on uncomplicated happy love affairs are
rare in fiction gamble claims that
Moore's characters tend to be loners who
experience a link between sex and erotic
Annihilation do carry some weight
regardless Moore's positioning of jewel
is an unrepentant loner also allows more
to take liberties with traditional
romantic conventions for example in
Black God's kiss when jeral's only male
counterpart Guillaume injures her Pride
by overrunning her castle Jarrell
travels to a plutonian land to secure a
weapon capable of defeating him the
weapon proves to be a supernatural kiss
which in a parody of the classic fairy
tale Motif she uses to kill Guillaume
only after Guillaume Falls dead at her
feet does she admit to herself a
repressed sexual attraction was probably
responsible for some portion of her Fury
nevertheless Guillaume is dead and in
black odd shadow jirrell's guilt will
compel her to vention Orpheus like to
the underworld to silence his whales and
free his soul similarly in the dark land
the dark God pav abducts geral's
dreaming mind and announces that she
will rule with him as Queen over the
land of Roma jirrell eventually defeats
pav remarkably and probably
significantly with the aid of a bridal
gown
if nothing else here's the conclusion of
this Jarrell like Smith is a fascinating
early experiment by an author willing to
flout convention and explore the
creative possibilities of an interplay
between different generic conventions so
once again we see the both you know
willing to work within the genre and use
whatever she wants to uh side to CL
Moore and at the same time pushing the
envelope constantly actually rupturing
the envelope we might say
Susan gubar and cl more in the
conventions of women's science fiction
writes
the placing of the juriel stories in
what looks like the chivalric Middle
Ages raises crucial questions about the
connection between women and sword and
sorcery fiction the pre-industrial
quasi-medieval Locale seems to
legitimize the commitment to revenge and
the possibility of the emergence of an
Amazon like Queen both of which find
Fuller expression later on in judgment
night and certainly jirl's legendary
prototypes Saint Joan of Arc and Judith
sustain the revisionary Mythic impulse
we've traced throughout Moore's early
stories but here prospective readers can
only be urged to find these stories
which serve as an interesting addict
addition to the other representations of
women warriors from La fee sodata folk
song to Marlene Dietrich Maxine Han
Kingston and Ann McCaffrey's singing
female spaceship what's important from
the point of view of the history of
women's sci-fi is that Gerald's
leadership and her conquests which
inevitably lead her to front her
simultaneous dread and desire for male
Mastery suggests that Science Fiction
and Fantasy provided more with the
opportunity to locate the power struggle
between the sexes in a fantastic past or
future where its outcome is uncertain or
at least not entirely inevitable
so lots and lots of interesting
points of view on these stories and we
come back again to chifalo's gendered
and gentrified bodies uh dissertation
and there's a few other things I want to
bring up here and then you know we we
can think about so uh
we we see contributions by other sword
and sorcery authors are unfortunately
marginalized despite assertions by
critics that among those Works exist
beacons of superior literary merit with
particular deference to Moore's GRL of
jury series Al Sprague de Camp notes
that fantasy readers consider now this
is a wonderful line bad more to still be
better than many writers best
morcock argues that of the stories
published in a similar vein to those of
Howard Robert Howard's Conan of Samaria
quote Catherine L Moore was probably the
best of these her female protagonist
girelle of Jory was an Amazon driven to
martial and occult practices in order to
avenge her wrongs the story had all of
Howard's Drive were rather better
written and certainly more consistent
going on from here there's a discussion
of Nicole ml Heinz Kearney critically
examining the Journey of the first
female sword and sorcery hero named URL
of Jory in Black God's kiss as an effort
to reclaim her dignity from The Invader
who steals her castle subjugates her
people and denies her feminine female
masculinity when he seizes her helmet
and forces a kiss on her lips she argues
that more
de-reifies that is uh on you know undoes
the the sort of essentialism or the
thinness of gender and reifies sexuality
through the course of this tale gender
is exposed as performance
sexuality is emphasized and exposed as
biology in a genre that is
hypersexualized bodies at its core this
is so impactful for Emma Heights Kearney
who views Moore's fiction as conducting
this groundbreaking theoretical work
nearly 50 years prior to Judith Butler's
publication of gender trouble which if
you don't know is asserting that gender
is not something rooted in our very
nature it is performative it's something
that we take on something that we work
with right
other emerging yet prominent criticism
on the value of revisiting CL Moore's
sword and sorcery and the girelle of
jori's character in particular includes
Eileen Donaldson's studies of female
action heroism and Judith Jack
halberstam's female masculinity to
present jirell's character as a
performance of female masculinity
Donaldson argues that jirell is the
first female Warrior to appear in
speculative fiction and that her
performance of masculinity is channeled
through the warrior role
she displays as well as the indirect and
direct characterizations of jirrell is
physically strong violent authoritative
and possessing her own sexual agency
this performance is made even more
significant by virtue of The Facts of
the time when these Tales were published
the 1930s and the tale and that the
tales likely constitute the first
appearance of what they're calling
female masculinity and speculative
fiction right CL Moore herself is a
reader and contributor of weird Tales
one of the pulp magazines that featured
Howard's works of sword and sorcery she
wrote to fellow author H.P Lovecraft
praising his talents and those of Howard
here's what she says the best weird
story I ever read was I think you're
outside the outsider and close to that
for me anyhow runs Robert E Howard's
worms of the Earth
perhaps it was because this was the
first of his stories I'd read and it
brought home to me very vividly the
possibilities of that type of fiction
even when it appears in the pulps I'm a
tremendous admirer of Mr Howard's work
at his best he's very near Perfection it
seems to me and even at his goriest and
and blood and thunder yes there's a
Lusty Vitality about everything he
writes that makes a story in golf one in
the in the vividus most living sort of
way Exquisite and fantastic enough to
lift one clear out of the present now
that is what Moore herself does in the
GRL of jewelry stories and and her other
works as well isn't it and particularly
with the vividness the attentiveness
that she has not only to as we've
discussed already scenery world
The Narrative landscape but to what is
going on with her characters
uh going on with this there's another uh
coming back to thinking about
sexuality and gender Moore's sword and
sorcery fiction is capable of navigating
this space between serving as mere
entertainment and serving as a platform
for Meaningful social discourse these
Tales involve swashbuckling adventure
and Supernatural characters or event
like events like any work of heroic or
Epic Fantasy as well as previously
indicated setting character and plot
tropes however sword and sorcery is also
capable of presenting
multi-faceted representation of socially
erected forms of gender expression so
you can do all the other stuff and also
play around with gender the drama of
sword and sorcery extends Beyond The
Superficial Adventure plot to challenge
underlying social constructs of
ideological apparatuses evidencing
conventional expectations of masculinity
or femininity what it is to be a man
what it is to be a woman right conflicts
of gender performance are a Trope
arguably as integral
to the sword and sorcery genre as the
perceived elements of Macho muscle-bound
male heroes or plots of Adventure across
eroticized continents some sort of
sorcery narratives create worlds where
men and women liberate themselves from
social constraints of identity imposed
by sexist oppressive and hegemonic
systems like the white supremacist
masculinism of patriarchal traditional
masculinity those worlds like the worlds
that we just discussed earlier become
spaces where those living in the social
World realize their existence as
legitimate beings despite using Judas
Butler's terms being illegible
unrealizable unreal and illegitimate
and then you know
chefalo goes on to say that
um what is what is happening here is
this empowers CL more to become leader
uh selmore's jury to become jeral to
become leader of Jory and to defend her
realm and herself from persecution
and then she goes on or he goes on and
talks about GRL as being a character
that exists parallel to Conan rather
than being Conan's Offspring right
offering a separate model but a
connected one
and um
as a Critic of uh science fiction Scott
Sanders discusses the adversarial
Essence to Tales of speculative fiction
they relay the dichotomic world view of
a society determined by adversarial
pairings and here we get something
really quite interesting
so women can be presented as inferior
blending into the scenery or setting
well they can also present men as
Superior Central to the action
when women are featured prominently it
can be accompanied by a fixation
on their procreative power presented as
something other that instills both fear
and mystery to typically rational male
observers so there's a you know binary
being erected there and this is what
Scott Sanders says in much of the genre
women in nature bear the same features
both are mysterious irrational
instinctive both are fertile and
Mindless both Inspire wonder and Dread
and the hero both are objects of male
Conquest
just as men in sci-fi and body
Consciousness the agency through which
nature knows itself so women embody
fertility the agency by which nature
reproduces itself men belong to the
realm of the Mind women in nature to the
no mind women are the bearers of Life
men are life's interpreters and Masters
now that can be subverted and undone
that goes on this inherent contrast
forms a thematic Cornerstone to the
sword and sorcery works of Cl Moore as
male and female are posited in an
oppositional relationship in every
Journal of jury story as is the symbolic
contrast between light and dark now what
would we expect there well men are light
women are dark right
but it's reversed
where Sanders identifies what is male as
the knower in speculative fiction and
what is female as what is known and the
tales of girol of Jory the masculine are
the transgressors and the female
feminine are the transgress the
masculine is the same assailant and The
Feminine is the victim the masculine is
the corrupter and The Feminine is the
Redeemer while more utilizes this
oppositional structure she also disrupts
it Jerrell frequently assumes the role
of the assailant by taking up her sword
and defending herself from the entities
that would overwhelm her but she's also
the victim in her dominated relationship
to the antagonist displayed at the
beginning of the very first story black
God's kiss she transgresses the laws of
nature by entering and traversing
underworlds or Realms beyond the laws of
reality and she navigates and performs
both
masculine and feminine roles and here's
another vital difference that's being
signaled jarella is also not defined by
her procreative power she has never
literally or figuratively exploited as a
referent for a maternal body
jarella is not a pre-symbolic emblem of
non-paternal causality or some
teleological conception of maternal
instinct
jirrell transgresses maternal
assumptions of female and woman she is
simultaneously the assailant and the
victim the corrupter and the Redeemer
masculine and feminine this is evidence
in the black Gods kiss where she ingests
the androgynous energies of the black
God to avenge the transgression against
Guillaume the same act that poisons
defeats and kills her to her Mentor
becomes an act of redemption as she
Mourns for him finding love for her
Tormentor and so that's you know just
some selections from a very very long uh
dissertation about this but you notice
some key common elements coming up in
this
namely that in these GRL of Jory stories
what we see is not a complete like and
deliberate I'm going to undermine
everything look how clever I am and you
know uh subverting the patriarchy or
anything like that more just does it
right with this character and
she does it so well that readers love it
at least most readers right does it well
enough to become an inspiration for
other female writers and male writers
later on to open up a field for a
different way of looking at gender and
sexuality erotics and uh violence
so there's a lot really going on in
these short stories packed into such a
small amount of time and you know able
to be encapsulated in a fairly short
volume
one key philosophical theme that I think
is particularly important and
interesting in CL Moore's work in
general but especially in the URL of
jury stories is the centrality of
emotional reactions and drives and one
of the things that we're going to see is
if there's one particular
emotion that is not necessarily just
driving her but emblematic of her It is
anger rage that that is discussed in
place after place and in the first four
stories it plays a role in you might say
saving the day in the fifth and the
sixth story though it turns out that
although she will have these angry
reactions
it's not actually going to resolve the
situation and other emotions are going
to be explored so in you know black
God's kiss and uh in in the second one
uh the you could say the companion piece
to Black Gods kiss black God Shadow what
we're going to see is that she's angry
with
um this guy who you know at first he's
beating her Guillaume right and we we
see her recounting how angry she is
right the fury in her eyes all these
sorts of things that we find going on uh
the priest you know saying oh it'd be
better if you gave yourself to him and
she's like no I'll never do that right
so she brings back this deadly kiss from
the blackout and then we get something
really interesting going on right
um she seeks a weapon as as we find out
and she says a weapon against a man I so
hate that upon Earth there's none
terrible enough for my need and uh she
says I hate him with all my heart right
and what does she get from the black God
this kiss which then she can give to him
and on the way back she's getting closer
and closer to death closer and closer to
something Beyond Death as a result and
then she kisses Guillaume
it was a long kiss
and then she saw the Readiness of him
draining away in the rigidity of stone
coming over his scarred features only
his eyes remained alive she was glad
she'd wanted him to understand what it
cost to take jory's kiss unbidden so
anger was was motivating him but then
something else happens
she saw something cold and alien seeping
through him permeating him slowly with
some unnamable emotion which no man
could ever have experienced before she
could not name it but she saw it in his
eyes some Dreadful emotion
never made for Flesh and Blood to know
some iron despair such as only an
unguessable being from the gray formless
void could have felt before too
hideously alien for any human creature
to endure more has this capacity you
know whereas Lovecraft will talk about
the unnameable and unspeakable more does
this with emotions are
possibilities of emotion are vulnerable
to those of other beings
she goes It goes on and now came a
physical change watching she was aghast
to think in her own body and on her own
soul she'd born the seed of this
Dreadful flowering did not wonder that
her heart is slowed under the unbearable
weight of it
she saw a trickle of blood from his
mouth as if he'd bitten through his lip
in the agony of this new
incomprehensible emotion and it goes on
a little bit more from his lips broke a
long slow Cry of such utter inhuman
strangeness jirrell felt coldness
Rippling through her veins and she put
up her hands to her ears to shut it out
it meant something it expressed some
Dreadful emotion that was neither sorrow
nor despair nor anger but infinitely
alien and infinitely sad
and he dies and then of course she
encounters her own emotions
It Came Upon her what she'd done she
knew why such heavy violence had flooded
her whenever she thought of him knew the
price she must pay for taking a gift
from a demon she knew there was no light
anywhere in the world now that he um was
gone right
in Black God's Shadow it begins with her
remembering Guillaume so hatefully
magnificent in his armor grinning down
on her from her own dice in her own
castle Hall where her own dead soldiers
lay scattered on the bloody Flags right
even now anger swept like a flame across
her memory and anger in answer to the
arrogance and Scorn of that conqueror's
kiss yet was it anger was it hatred and
how had she to know until he lay dead at
last of her at her vengeful feet that it
was not hate that bubbled up so hotly
whenever she remembered the insolence of
his arms right and then she starts
getting this haunting by him and she
goes to try to save him and she
encounters his shade in the world below
something about this black shambling
thing something indefinable and obscene
reminder of Guillaume some aptness of
line and angle periodied in the ugly
Hulk the long clear lines of Guillaume
the Poise of his high head she could not
put a finger in any definite likeness
but it was unmistakably there and it was
all the ugliness of Guillaume all is
cruelty and arrogance and brutish force
it might have been a picture of
Guillaume sins with just enough of his
virtues left to point at its
dreadfulness right and she thinks about
how his punishment was so just yet so
infinitely unjust what torment the black
Gods kiss had wrought upon him to dwell
on the full frightful realization of his
own sins chained to the actual
manifestation sufferingly eternally in
the obscene shape that was so undeniably
himself his worst and lowest self it was
just in a way he had harsh and cruel man
in life but the very fact that such
punishment was Agony to him proved a
higher self within his complex Soul
something Noble and fine which writhed
away from the Unspeakable thing himself
so the very fineness of him was a weapon
to torture his soul turned against him
even as his sins were turned now she's
going to try to recover him from the
black God
and what happens there
she feels herself turning into a similar
image and then what saves her the first
time from a long way off in another time
in world came the memory of guillaume's
arms about her and the scornful press of
his mouth over hers it did not happen to
her it had happened to someone else
someone human and alive in a Faraway
place but the memory of it shot like
fire through the rigidness of the body
she'd almost forgotten was hers so cold
and still it was it broke the ice the
Raging fever which was both hate and
love it broke the ice that bound her for
a moment only and in that moment she
fell to her knees at the dark statue's
feet and burst into shuddering sobs and
the hot tears flowing were like fire to
thaw her soul the awful weight of the
despair which was no human emotion
lifted by degrees
then we find again
she faces the black God and what saves
her this time
again she felt herself congealing
through and through as the ice of
Eternal nothingness thickened upon her
soul and the gray dim formless place she
remembered took shape about her and the
immense weight of that iron despair
descended again on her shuddering
spirits
sharply through this stab the the fire
hot memory that had awakened upon hers
the grip of his male arms and again she
knew the flash of violence that might
have been hate or love and warmth flowed
through her again in a sustaining tide
and she fought all the deeps of warmth
and Humanity in her she Drew up to fight
the cold all the violence of emotion to
combat the terrible apathy which gripped
her once and was stretching out again
for her soul
okay
then we have a third time time right
once again the black God's presence
folded like a cloak about her almost she
welcomed it here was something she knew
how to fight she called up the memories
of hate and love and anger to hurl
against it thinking as she did so that
perhaps one who would live less
violently than herself and had lesser
stories of passions to recall might
never be able to combat the God's death
chill she remembered laughter the
singing and gaiety she remembered
Slaughter and blood in the wild clang of
mail
she remembered kisses in the dark and
the hard grip of men's arms about her
body
but she's finding that it's you know
difficult
for her to fight against the the dark
God these the seeping of the iron
despair against her brain
she there was one small spark of her
that God could not free she felt him a
sailing it
helplessly she felt herself whirling to
and fro among currents she had never
felt before she had no substance then
one of the small vaguenesses blew
against her and threw her and in the
instant of its passage she caught the
faint vibration of her name she knew
this was the voice that had summoned her
Guillaume and with that instance Union
something as sustaining as life itself
flashed through her wonderfully a bright
spark that swelled and grew and blazed
she wins
so human emotions the store of emotions
that she can bring up allows her to
defeat this alien foreign apathetic
entity that has captured Guillaume
we go into the third story
um Jarrell and magic and she is able to
break out of you know this this uh
terrible Cosmic what should we call it
glimpse into
eternity and into her own life that
jarism has imprisoned her in but what
happens
there's an emotion
a mounting a motion too great to have
name once again a nameless emotion
two complexly blending Agony and grief
and hatred and love and Rebellion so
strong that all the rest of the
stupendous thing before her was blotted
out
in the Gathering storm of what seed in
her innermost Consciousness she was
aware of nothing but that overwhelming
emotion and it was boiling into one
great unbearable explosion of violence
in which now notice what happens here
rage took precedence over all rage at
life for permitting such pain to be
raised at charism for forcing her into
memory such rage that everything shook
before it and melted and ran together in
a heat of rebellion and something
snapped the Panorama reeled and shivered
and collapsed into the dark of
semi-oblivion once again her anger is
what not only sustains her but breaks
through and allows her to conquer the
magic that is binding her we see also in
the dark land anger is going to play an
important role right she's in this land
uh with pave the the king of Rome and he
gets angry at her as well but blind with
Fury Jarrell ripped his hand away and
fell back one step in a swirl of black
skirts scorching anger in her voice
licked up in matching Flames so hotly
that her speech was broken and
breathless as she choked in a half
whisper never touch me again you black
hell dweller before God you'd never have
dared if you'd left me a knife to defend
myself with I swear I'll tear the eyes
out of your head if I feel the weight of
your hand on me again yours you filthy
wizard you'll never have me never if I
must die to escape you she choked into
silence not for lack of words but
because the mounting Fury that seemed up
in her throat drowned out any further
sound right but in this case her anger
is not able to save the day as it did in
the past
but she Encounters this white witch a
corpse-like creature who terrifies her
Gerald does feel fear at many points as
well but
the White Witch reveals to her that she
can use this
Flames this anger to kill POV by
destroying his own Flame
the hot reserves of her anger against
him flooded over and strength like wine
boiled up through her body in one
tremendous burst of fierce energy she
hurled every ounce of her newly won
power against the flame his flame
triumphantly she saw it flicker there
was a moment of guttering Twilight then
abruptly the light went out and red
flame his flame and blue flame vanished
in a breath a crashing Darkness like the
weight of Falling Skies dropped
thunderously about her
voice calls wordlessly and it turns out
that he was not just a person in the
land he was the land itself and now she
is in darkness
the White Witch says I would have you
see the darkness that is pob and Romana
clearly invisibly so you might
understand what manner of lover I had
she saw the darkness it was tremendous
beyond the power of any human
perceptions to endure save in the brief
flash she had of it right
um and she manages to make her way back
to the land of the living her anger has
in this case saved her but also almost
killed her
in quest of the star Stone
girol is going to get angry she's going
to get angry at the wizard she's going
to get angry at Northwest Smith
but her anger is actually not going to
help her this time
instead
it's a different play of emotions
Northwest Smith is being tortured by the
wizard franga with these Suarez star
swirls that are
um
you know burning him alive Jiro we find
had been watching with mingling emotions
as the stars begin to swirl into flames
about her tall enemy Northwest Smith
Triumph was foremost among them as
resentment and fury were foremost among
her thoughts just then
but somehow she who looked down heartily
on torture many times before now fellow
queer hot weakness rising in her as the
Stars became brushing flames and she saw
the sweat beating Smith's forehead in
the fist clench against The Rock
Smith is being tortured to compel him to
get jirrell to give up the star Stone
and she admires Smith because of the
torture that he's willing to endure a
sudden Fury of sympathy
and hot emotion rushed over her a sudden
gust of pain in his pain
stop it stop let him go free I give you
the star Stone
and then Smith says Jarrell Jarrell you
fool don't do it he'll kill us all she's
taking the star Stone out and then Smith
despairingly through the Dazzle of the
Flames as the leather parted suddenly
blindingly the Stars don't flamed in her
hands and he will kick it
out of her hands in just a moment right
she and and he are seeing what's what's
going on and the star Stone will break
so it's in this case it's no longer
hatred anger Fury that is saving the day
it's
sympathy it's respect it's something
else
now that's not the case in the final
story hellsgard
this is one where fear
predominates
jirrell is being used essentially as
bait and actually her anger her Fury
draws out the ghost
who's you know she thinks that they're
looking for his treasure actually the
ghost himself is the treasure for these
people that she is captured by the ghost
kisses her Embraces her grips her with
an iron
arm that she cannot get away from and we
read choking with impotent Fury she
tried to struggle tried to scream but
there was no chest to push for leverage
no body to Arch away from she could not
resist she could only make dumb animal
sounds and her throats sealed in behind
the storming violation of that mouth she
is confronted herself a violent person
with greater violence from this ghost of
Android
what do we find going on later on a
second attack by Android and she's taken
to a different dimension by a a
whirlwind that he is and then
seemingly
she's saved
what happens
she wakes up right Panic swelling in her
throat quieted in an instant as she saw
the precious molding thing lying on its
side at her elbow a little thing it's
iron wrenches iron hinges Rusty it's
leather whitened and eaten with rot from
two centuries and a nameless dripping
place but safe unopened he picked it up
or she picked it up shaking it
experimentally this is the treasure
right and then she looks around her and
she sees glutted satiety in these people
the Obscure lusting she'd seen in their
eyes
and she talks to
um the the leader of them Alaric and he
says I could not have explained to you
last night what it was I wanted of
Android so I said it was the treasure
you understood that
and she says well what is it that you
did want what are you and he says a
hunter of undeath a drinker of undeath
when I can find it my people and I lust
after that dark force which the ghosts
of the violent dead and gender and we
travel far sometimes between feastings
I wonder if any man who's not tasted it
could guess the utter Ecstasy of
drinking up the undeath of a strong
ghost feeling that black power pouring
into you in deep deep drafts as you suck
it down a thirst that strengthens as you
drink feel Darkness spreading through
every vein more sweetly than Wine more
intoxicating to be drunk on undeath a
joy almost unbearable and what do we see
on jarrell's part
a strong shutter that Rose in the pit of
her stomach and ran strongly and
shakingly along her limbs the obscene
ecstasy that air looks inward looking
Eyes dwelt Upon was a thing she would
not even see in retrospect through
another's words and eyes and they let
her go and you know that she thinks last
night was a memory and a nightmare to
forget the vortex of violence out of
which she'd snatched this box last night
the power and Terror of the things she
treasured so long
what lay Within
something akin to Android
so she's going to give this to her worst
enemy and that's that's essentially
where the story ends so we move from
anger and Revenge being the ways in
which she will be saved to other
emotions taking the four in these
stories a great descriptive power and
imaginative scope on the part of Cl
Moore when it comes to the human and the
inhuman emotions and that is where we
are going to leave off so we can stay
more or less on track and on time with
this discussion there's certainly more
that could be said about these so
interesting stories but I think we've
covered enough at this point so I hope
that you'll read the GRL of story
jirelle of Jory stories and perhaps
enjoy them as much as you can tell all
that I myself have in the course of
delving into this wonderful heroine and
her worlds
[Music]
thank you